all right flo-jo thank you very much
so as you mentioned I'm a software
engineer although I tend to have a
passion for pretty much all things data
so anytime there is a question about you
know some sort of analysis or how we can
use data to visualize visualize data to
actually come up with a better idea of
how to solve something I tend to be the
person like raising my hand and saying
like oh yeah I work on that for you so I
didn't spit a lot of weekends actually
doing extra work it seems like um but it
works out great because I get to you
know dabble a little bit in things like
visualizing Geographic data and I get to
come here and give talks on things like
that so the first thing that I wanted to
do before we actually go through the
talk is just to kind of give you some
ideas for my reasons for this talk as I
mentioned I'm a software engineer I'm
not necessarily a geographic information
you know it's like specialists or
anything like that so why did I actually
want to give a talk on this and you know
a lot of that came from some work that I
was doing for a course on the side and
as I was working on that of course I
already knew you know maps master quite
beautiful maps are quite intuitive just
about everybody you know can take a look
at a map and you know see some data on
there and they instantly have some idea
of what what message you're trying to
convey which of course makes maps
extremely powerful but I think the other
thing that I didn't realize whenever I
started looking into this was just how
complex maps are and how much work it
takes to actually create good maps and
that actually made me want to give this
talk and hopefully share with you some
of the things that I found that I found
were fascinating maybe a little geeky
hopefully not too geeky
at times or whatever and you know
hopefully the majority of you in here
are not GIS specialists as well and
you'll actually get something out of
this so with that in mind let's take a
look at the overview so the very first
thing that I'm going to do is I'm going
to go over the power of maps I want to I
basically have a little anecdote that I
want to tell and just kind of give you
some idea of just how useful Maps can be
they were going to go into the main
problem of maps and this is the thing
that kind of fascinated me and there's
probably quite a few of you in this room
that already know this but it's well
there's moments in time whenever I
I never really thought about it very
much but whatever I got it was just kind
of huh
I wanted to tell everybody about it so
it's one of the reasons for doing this
talk so we'll see the you know what I'm
talking about here in a little bit when
we get to the problem of maps next we'll
go into how maps are made it will
actually you know since we're talking
about the problem and we want to see the
actual like I guess how the sausage is
made the underlying bits and pieces that
actually come together to make this
complex thing come about following that
will actually go into a few tips and
everything on how to create good Maps
and then finally I have a few examples
for you that I've put together in Python
using mainly base map which is a toolkit
for matplotlib and I have at least one
example where I'm reproducing one of
those using folium which is a Python
library to leaflet j/s so let's go ahead
and take a look at the power of maps so
my story basically comes with the color
outbreak of 1854 so I think it was
around 1830 132 color actually made its
way into London and started to make its
way across the city and in 1854 it hits
Soho with a huge impact in a matter of
days over a hundred people had already
perished from the disease and by before
the end of this outbreak I think it was
something like 600 600 plus people 616
people I believe died from cholera just
in Soho alone so basically you know the
town needed a savior of some sort and
luckily a man stepped up named John snow
to actually take care of this so
actually not the correct John snow this
is the correct John snow and that is
actually how real heroes look like early
real data heroes so
probably not the ABS that you would
expect but you know so dr. John snow
he's a physician working in working in
Soho and at the time it was thought that
basically coloro was coming from
basically breathing in like the polluted
air that was that was the the main
thought that everybody had and that you
weren't going to tell us any other what
any other reason that this is actually
taking place so he had an idea and
basically what he did was he decided to
use data to actually prove his point and
he took a look at the map and he
basically took all the different
locations where cholera had sprouted up
and he plotted him down on a map of Soho
essentially one of the very first
density maps which we'll talk about a
little bit later and what he found was
that all of these incidences kind of
clustered around one area in particular
and that was a water pump on Broad
Street so he went to he went to the
higher-ups in the community whatever
with this data and basically said look
color isn't being spread through the air
it's being spread through the water it's
contaminated water and we need to shut
this off and because of this data
visualization you know this happened
they actually took the handle off the
pump and no one was a lot of drink from
the water and in no time whatsoever
color are cleared up in Soho
so maps save lives they are extremely
powerful so with that in with that out
of the way a little anecdote for why I
love maps so much let's look at what are
the problems with maps specifically what
is the problem with maps and now George
box the statistician had a famous quote
which I think is slightly apocryphal I
think it's a little more mixed-up than
this but it goes along lives of all
models are wrong but some are useful
well so are maps and I'm actually going
to claim that one
I'm sure someone else said it just let
me have it
so anyway let's take a look at the world
as we know it so most of us this is
probably how we see the world or
whatever right this is what you call the
Mercator projection and we'll learn a
little bit later what a projection is
but basically it's one way to look at
the world on a flat two-dimensional
surface
the problem is that this map is
incorrect if you look up here in the
upper left corner it's actually a little
bit to the slightly left of the center
you'll see Greenland notice that it's uh
it's nearly the same size as Africa
believe so
the problem is Greenland is no Africa on
the left you'll actually see the
Mercator projection with Greenland
overlaid over top of Africa and on the
right you'll see how big it actually is
in real life so and to drive the point
home a little further this is the true
size of Africa with several of the
countries that we know United States
China India big ones you know laid over
top of it you can see just how huge
Africa is now the real world and you
know this is just sort of the real world
is actually slightly different if you
notice this one looks a little bit weird
and this is a famous scene from West
Wing which I never actually saw the show
but um it's a fantastic bit Eunice Lee
and this is literally how I felt like oh
my god you're telling me that this is
all wrong but if you notice there's
these little let me go back one there
are these uh these little round circles
and I'm going to totally butcher this
pronunciation but tissot indicatrix YZ
and I did a lot of work looking up all
the pronunciations for everything before
I came in so hopefully this is halfway
decent what these do is just kind of
indicate to you the distortion that
you're seeing on the map in that
particular area well you should
hopefully see is a nice round circle in
most places and you do see that a lot
throughout the center of the map the
equator is obviously perfect and then as
you go out from there it gets a little
worse but notice that this one doesn't
nearly look as bad as the more creative
projection we had it's only two when you
get to the very extremes at the poles
that you really see a lot of distortion
in those in each indicatrix indicatrix
so let me speed back where I am okay so
back to the Mercator projection so again
you can see like the now we're seeing it
with the indicator sees and you can
every time you go away just one step
from that from the equator you're
actually seeing the thing get bigger and
bigger and bigger so it's actually
ballooning each of these things up the
closer you get to the poles so that's
the major problem and we know it's a
problem for every map because of this
man so Carl Friedrich Gauss and this is
the one that I don't know how to
pronounce he wrote up this theory EMA
agrees 'i'm remarkable theorem I can
pronounce that one and basically the
main thing behind it was that or at
least one of the the main things for us
was that the earth just cannot be
displayed on on a map without some
distortion and you can kind of picture
that you know I think the main way that
you do that is by picturing an orange
draw the draw the world on top of that
fill that orange and then try to lay it
flat and you'll notice that you get
something like this where the world just
basically falls apart at different
places even better take a balloon draw
it on there and pull it apart and you'll
see all these all these continents
towards the top and the bottom of the
balloon start to stretch out and you can
see where this distortion comes from and
now all of this comes from basically
having to create a map projection and
you heard me mention that earlier and a
map projection essentially just is a
mathematical equation or an algorithm
for taking points on a 3d surface and
putting it on to a 2d planar surface so
I thought I'd go a little bit deeper
into what are all the basic components
of that because it gets even more
complex once you get to that point so
this is basically a tale of two
coordinate systems
so we already know that what we want
essentially is a planar or Cartesian
coordinate system that's what we want to
map to look like and you can call that a
projected coordinate system but what we
start from is a geographic coordinate
system so let's take a little closer
look at what that is the geographic
coordinate system is basically made up
of a handful of things one of which is
an angular measurement so in our case
it'll be degrees so latitude longitude
you need some sort of surface that you
project those actual and angular
measurements on to so that'll be what we
call a spheroid or an ellipsoid and
those two things are used
interchangeably and then
and this is the other part that kind of
amazes me is that you actually have to
take that spheroid and figure out where
you want to place it in relation to the
rest of the earth you would just assume
that you would put it in the center of
the earth but that's not necessarily
100% true so let's take a look at a
cross-section of our geographic
coordinate coordinate system and you can
kind of see just how this gets simpler
and simpler and simpler as we look at it
so we start off with a picture of the
earth which is the terrain in green and
it's just bumpy and all over the place
right and we want to simplify that
so we'll tend to take that down to an
ellipsoid or I'm sorry a a geode which
is more or less a way of saying like if
there were no bits of way on sticking
out if there was just gravity where
would the earth be or whatever right so
you end up with something that's much
smoother and you're just calculating
exactly where the edges of the air
should be according to gravity another
way of looking at that is the mean sea
level and then from there you go down
even further because even at that point
you know the geoid is fairly irregular
so we want something even closer to or
even simpler to work with so we go to a
spheroid or an ellipsoid and now we have
our model that we're going to base
everything on now we just need to figure
out how the hell to put it so you end up
with this idea of both local or regional
datum is what it's called or geocentric
datum and the idea of a datum is
basically twofold you have the spheroid
that we just mentioned and then you have
the position relative to the center of
the earth now traditionally you would
basically put this thing kind of closer
to your side of the country I mean if
you're going to draw up a map you want
it to be as close as possible and if you
notice down here at the bottom that's
where I want to put it right problem is
on the other side of the earth it
doesn't look very good so they move it
to their side and then you end up with
two maps that when you try to put them
together they just do not fit so you get
to today's day and age and we have GPS
and everybody wants to be able
everywhere know where everything is so
now we have to have something called a
geocentric data so we actually have to
position it on the center of the earth
and that is what you see you see over
here on the right so now you have the
first piece of the puzzle right you have
basic
where the 3d coordinates come from and
now you need to put it and turn them to
turn those things into the 2d
coordinates and you do that using map
projections which we mentioned and there
are three basic types of map projections
cylindrical conical and azimuth Oh
so in each of these makes you know very
intuitive sense whenever you look at it
right so I'll just go over like 101 or
so so the cylindrical one imagine a
piece of paper that you've just wrapped
around the earth you stick a light bulb
right in the center and turn it on and
it just projects onto that and if it
stayed there you know I think like a
photo paper or whatever right just cut
it open and pull it open and there's
your mat same thing with conical and
Zima though I think of it as just
projecting now one of the things that
you'll hear people talk about is tangent
versus secant so up here you'll see that
is your tangent line and of course
that's where you have no distortion
whatsoever you can also have a secant
line where you imagine that you take
that cylinder you just keep constricting
it further and further until it cuts
through the center of the earth now you
have two spots on the earth where no
distortion exists whatever so there's
different reasons for doing all of this
and tons of different reasons for
actually choosing one or the other
versus secant versus tangent and
everything and these are all the things
that we're going to use whenever we put
together our examples later later using
base map so that's the whole situation
right the problem taking it from the 3d
to the 2d and I think this is actually
one of the things are really interested
me here whenever I looked at it I was
just you know blown away I was like man
I had no idea whatever I sit down and I
mean the hardest thing to me typically
in the past and there was quite a few
that a few of you that might not
actually realize this was just folding
the map back together luckily I don't
have to do that part of me more but
still maps extremely complex so given
that there's all these trade-offs that
you have to make when actually choosing
a map projection when you're looking at
designing a good map one of the very
first questions of course then would be
which map projection do you choose and
of course there's going to be three main
things that all these map projections
decide to make sure
on first angle so you can think of it as
you know basically the angle from one
continent to another or whatever it so
you want to keep that as as as stable as
possible if you're trying to plan out
trips area we already saw one example
where area is being highly distorted and
that's the Mercator projection and then
finally distance so let's take a look at
each one of these things each one of
these map projections making trade-offs
in each of these areas
so first is conformal or angular and
Mercator is an actual example of that
the reason this map was created now
remember I said all maps are wrong but
some of them are actually useful and
this one actually has a really good
purpose it was originally made for
sailors navigating at sea the nice thing
about having something where the angles
are all correct is basically I can sit
down and I can draw a straight line from
one place to another and they I get a
constant bearing at sea or whatever in
my vessel so it makes it very easy for
me to navigate from one place to another
course that's at the expense of
Greenland looking like a giant but you
got to make a trade-off somewhere right
the other one that we saw is an equal
area map so obviously this is going to
be important imagine that you're
surveying land and you want to actually
figure out how big the the spots going
to be for a building that you're going
to put in now if you went with the last
one and you're billing in Greenland
there's a good chance you're not going
to have enough room for your building so
you want to make sure that you choose in
the right map for the right job an
equidistant of course just means like
now I can measure one point to another
and make sure that I have the right
measurement and it's not stretched out
like crazy now my favorite I have to say
out of all these is the Robinson
projection and the thing I liked about
it was the guy who came up with this
Arthur H Robinson he basically looked at
it from the point of view of let's make
this thing just look good and convey
information so he kind of went backwards
what he said was you know I started off
with something that I wanted and then I
actually figured out the math for it
most most cartographers go the other way
around right so the thing that I like
about this is from our point of view you
know there are two different types of
maps there's a reference map there's a
thematic map I'm not creating reference
maps I don't really care as much about
things being you know as accurate as
possible but what I do want to do is
convey data in the best
go away so Robinson that's basically
what he was trying to do and that's why
his map appeals to me so much and just
for a little side note xkcd actually has
his comic so go check it out afterwards
it actually goes on for a lot longer but
it's basically what your favorite map
projection says about you and Stan Lee
mine says I like coffee and beetles and
it's spot on so so choosing the right
map so now we've got we've let's see
what we've come from our journey from
figuring out how to create a map and
everything and what map projections to
use but now we need to figure out what
kind of thematic map that we want to
actually use to show our data and
examples of that are core plus density
maps propotional slash graduated and
cartograms so let's look at each one of
these one after another so here's an
example of a choropleth and what that
does is basically show data based on air
area sorry dot density mass we saw one
earlier that is the jon snow example and
we'll actually see how to create both of
these that's why I'm kind of skimming
past and really quickly here in just a
little bit a proportional slash
graduated symbol map so this is one
where it's actually simple as a similar
to the choropleth map but the nice thing
about this is that you could actually
change say the size of the symbol inside
based on based on the data that it's
representing and the nice thing there is
if you think of an electoral map all of
us have seen them half the time it looks
like the well actually more than half
time looks like the Democrats have no
chance of ever winning or at least tied
at best or whatever right and that's
because the majority of the votes come
from these really small states what it
for right so like you get up to Vermont
and all those kind of places or Delaware
I think whatever right I mean some of
these have like insane amounts of
electoral votes or whatever but they
have no landmass so you know the nice
thing about this is that you can kind of
get past that and it allows you to show
in a different way same with cartograms
so here is a modern-day version of a
electoral map basically distorting the
landmass as much as possible to try and
give you a better idea of exactly how
many votes you may have so once you've
chosen your map one of the next things
you may want to do is figure out how to
standardize your data you may want to
classify your data and there are a few
different ways here's just three of the
ways that I've
or whatever that I thought I'd write up
real quick equal intervals easy enough
basically you just pick a bunch of
classes based on the number of the range
in between so like 1 to 10 11 to 20 so
on quantiles here we want classes where
we want the same number of observations
in each class natural breaks is exactly
what it sounds like you're actually
looking for areas in the data where
seems like there is a nice natural break
between one class and another and all
these have advantages and disadvantages
equal intervals imagine that you have
extreme outliers then what you end up
with is like one or two classes with a
bunch of data in it and then something
way out there with you know nothing in
between or whatever right see natural
breaks all right the thinking will have
to give it and skim through a little bit
faster so anyway some of the
classification methods that I just
mentioned here and these are histograms
of the actual data and this is one of
the recommended ways of figuring out how
to classify your data take a look at the
histogram and a lot of things a lot of
times what you'll see is cartographers
we'll start off with a natural breaks
approach there's an algorithm called
Jenks which is essentially just k-means
for like a univariate data whatever
apply that first see what you get take a
look at the histogram and then you know
kind of fiddle with it a little bit
that's recommended so don't shy away
from looking at your data and trying to
do something by hand and not necessarily
algorithmic every time another thing
that you might want to do is choosing
the right colors right so sequential
data you know ordinal data and
everything you want to choose some sort
of a color line where basically you end
up with lightness being the main thing
that you're differentiating on right
that seems pretty layout pretty fairly
obvious divergent though you may want to
choose like two different colors where
lightness starts to differentiate in
magnitude and then qualitative you'll
want to have different groups
represented by all kinds of different
colors you want to make sure that you
choose the colors in a way that it
doesn't look like these could be you
know in any way shape or form
sequential whatever right so it becomes
really important to choose the right
color and without going into a lot of
theory what I'm going to recommend is
that you just go to color Brewer Cynthia
Brewer is like one of probably the most
popular cartographers in the world she
has
you know a few fantastic books and
everything I suggest you know checking
them out and Keller Brewer in particular
is where you want to want to look and
this is her own like product so and I
think I'm running out of time so let's
go ahead okay so quick quick
one more story to kind of show you the
importance of choosing the right things
so this is a an article that was in the
data blog from Washington Post critic
Chris Ingraham whatever fantastic
blogger and he basically pointed out
that Pew Research went through and they
looked at population growth right and
they created this map and they made all
kinds of problems the the two the two
which are the biggest ones are they
basically chose to classify their data
incorrectly there was I think something
like three hundred one hundred three
thousand one hundred thirty eight
different counties such that are in the
thing or sorry three thousand one or
forty one and out of those three
thousand hundred thirty-eight actually
show up in like one or two of the
classes so basically there's three
counties and all the rest of the classes
wrote it right so this is just a
horrible you can kind of see it right
there really kind of you know far off or
whatever right so he redesigned it and
what he did was he classified the data
correctly but then he also chose a
different color scheme because what you
have here is a divergence set of data
right you have people who places where
the population actually went down versus
places where the population without so
he chose two different colors to
represent that and you end up with a
totally different story here I've you
can actually see now that you know
through the south east down around the
Appalachian areas and everything you
know population went down whereas out
here in the West it actually started to
go up in California everything which is
kind of what you expect so all right I
actually made it there as much as I can
so I want to show you least one or two
examples before we leave and these are
all from a class that I put together for
a Riley math lot live for developers
anybody's interested hit me up
afterwards I got like a 50% discount if
you wanna check it out all the all the
code all everything that you see here is
all on github so I'll put this up so you
can actually get it so actually you
could just read through the whole entire
thing pretty much all the scripts for
the course are there so it's kind of
free already so let's look at at least
one or two of these before I run out of
all my time
so introduction to base map so base map
by the way is as I mentioned is the tool
pin sorry oh shoot whoops
displayed
alright nerd
sweet
all right so as I mentioned basemap is
the toolkit for matplotlib so I'm going
to skip past some of this stuff is just
basically like pulling everything in I'm
going to go straight down to notice here
you can actually say you know base map
supported projections you get a list of
every projection that you could possibly
want to choose from we're going to do
the Robinson projection as our example
since I said that's my favorite and you
want to create a base map specify its
projection and then for Robinson it's
really easy because basically it's
showing the entire row so you just want
to give it a center location so in this
case I'm giving it the Prime Meridian
and draw map boundaries Coast lines fill
continents draw countries a graticule by
the way if you if you haven't heard the
term whatever it's just basically the
the network that all of the latitude and
longitude make on a map and eventually
you get down to something that looks
like this I kind of skim through this
because I want to show you at least one
more if it's a little little bit more
interesting mainly because I want to
show you creating a another map that has
a little bit more to it so if we come
down here this is the core play sorry oh
yeah that better more
all right so here's a little bit of
different one basically I'm creating a
Lambert conformal conic projection so
it's the the cone version that we saw or
earlier it's conformal so it's it's
angles are all correct and notice here
that I actually have to specify
boundaries for the whole entire thing
now I'm since I'm only showing a portion
of the map or whatever you have to
specify which portion you want to show
this is why it becomes really important
to choose the right projection because
choose the wrong one
and you're showing a portion of the
earth where you know it's just distorted
as hell then you're basically showing
your person slike just the worst
possible representation of data you can
possibly come up with so choose the
right projection one of the nice thing
is you go into Google Maps you just
right-click on any point and you get the
actual Latin long and that allows you to
choose the lower left corner in the
upper right corner and just pop them in
here your projection chosen and then
notice down here you have lat and long
and remember I said a line could either
tangent or secant this is a case where
it's actually seeking I'm cutting
through the earth all right and I only
have five minutes left so I'm going to
have to cut it off early but again you
know it's like if you if you're
interested in these all every last one
of these are online eventually what you
end up with is a nice set of core plus
this is basically showing the
unemployment rates during the Great
Recession so I start off with 2006 year
before the Great Recession 2009 you can
actually see a lot of unemployment say
happen Michigan where you know
industries you know taking a big hit
down the southeast and on the west coast
that's the peak of the unemployment or
sorry the Great Recession and then
finally in 2014 when we gotten back to
normal
there's a little bit a little bit
picture a little bit bigger picture of
it and I guess to show you just one
other like idea of what you can do with
it I go through and I pull down all of
the San Francisco crime data and I map
that out in a dot density map using the
ArcGIS service so I'm actually pulling
down raster images at this point in time
as opposed to just showing vectorized
forms all right so I had to rush back
through you know a little bit of that
because I want to give at least a minute
or two see if anybody has any questions
so I'll just go ahead and cut it off
right there so any questions
questions yep over here sorry can you go
back to that code and explain what the
secant line was like I wouldn't know
what where to go get that number
yeah yep sorry that's okay
which one was it right actually a lot of
a lot of these so a lot of these is just
kind of guessing for me or whatever
right like what I'll do so you can have
you can actually take a look at the map
if you go to Google Maps and everything
and click on it you can see where the
latitude and longitude lines are and
depending on what I want to show like so
I'm just I just want to show the actual
United States of America so what I did I
think is I chose a Latin long that cut
one above it one below it and everything
so I think I actually put it a little
bit you know down so I have as much
distortion as possible above and below
and I guess it's a let me pull up the
United States map against that I think
what I did
and
just kind of playing around with it and
trying to find one that reduces the
distortion as much as possible and
actually with some of these honestly you
can just find ones where they recommend
a secant you know Latin long for you
okay so basically the first four numbers
were the corners of your bounding boxes
your single bounding box and then the
other two numbers were two lines that
were parallels yeah yeah they call it as
the the standard parallel the place
where there is just no distortion
whatsoever exactly how do in the crime
map how did you how did you convert the
natural language terms into longitude
and latitude it is crime from news
articles oh no no there's a yeah right
here there there's actually like a SFPD
website you can go to and download
everything in Jason and everything so
it's like fantastic and you get the
latitude and longitude and the nice
thing about your base map object is that
it actually itself acts as a it's a
function you can call it whatever right
and it is a map projection there it is
so you pass in here I'm grabbing the
latin hmong you pass that in and it'll
pass back to you arrays of x and y
coordinates so okay so it's math it's
matching those somehow in terms to
locations well yeah since I so and I
said each one of those which each one of
those crime locations whatever has a
lat/long that I download from the SFPD
side yeah any more questions okay let's
thank our speaker all right thank you